hey guys it's October 16th 2023 I'm Dave
Rubin this is the rubben report we are
live streaming on Rumble locals on
YouTube if you want to join us for the
postgame show Ruben report. locals.com
and uh oh in case you didn't know guys
we live in a wacky world and it's
getting wackier by the moment I'm going
to try to get you caught up over the
last couple days the weekend's worth of
news and uh and really what I want to
focus on today is sort of how the
narrative around all of this is Shifting
in real time and how the media you know
for two days Israel gets a little Grace
as they're literally not just burying
their dead but trying to figure out
where people are and there are still
dozens of hostages and missing people
and babies and all of the stuff but how
within basically 48 Hours the narrative
starts shifting and there should be no
more grace there we should be worried
about the people uh that did this or
support the people that did this we're
going to talk a little bit about how
some of this has kind of gone worldwide
with these just abs absolutely uh insane
uh protests all over the place of course
usually at college campuses I want to
connect that with what's become very
clear that uh BLM we we talked about it
last week how they obviously are
supporting Hamas but how they've been
able to really activate their foot
soldiers again you remember our Summer
of Love Back in 2020 when BLM and antifa
were rampaging through our cities and
destroying things and then magically it
just goes away one day suddenly it just
turns on again last week but it's not
BLM brand bred anymore it's Hamas
branded basically and how the media is
very confused about a lot of things but
occasionally because I wanted to do
something a little more on the positive
side today if possible occasionally some
light can break through the darkness and
there are some good people who make it
onto mainstream media and call out the
BS so it's an awful lot to cover today I
should note also uh that David and the
kids have coid and my sister-in-law
who's here has coid I'm the only one in
the house who does not have Co although
suddenly my I feel like I've got a
little something going on in my throat
but we are going to slog through it's
been uh it's been a crazy it's just like
every I think everyone in the world that
is paying attention to this to any
degree like it takes a toll on you like
try to imagine the people that are
actually going through this and I was
thinking all weekend like I was sort of
just like mentally drained and
physically drained I I I didn't work out
I didn't I didn't have a drink I was
just like I just kind of had nothing and
really was just taking care of the kids
uh and and of course that's not that's
not to ask for any sympathy or anything
like that like imagine what the real
victims are going through but I think
everyone that's watching this it it
takes a certain to uh toll on all of us
the the Doom scrolling and all that and
uh we got to figure out some ways out of
this so that's what I'm going to try to
do today before we get to it uh let me
talk to you guys about Mo Fox you guys
know that 60% of us pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day guys there's a better way I
want to tell you about moink you know
it's moo plus oink moink delivers
grass-fed and grass finish beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the moink difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farm stay
financially independent too you choose
the meat delivered in every box like
ribey chicken breast to pork chops to
Salmon plays and much more plus you can
cancel anytime Shark Tank host Kevin oir
called Mo's bacon the best bacon he's
ever tasted and they guarantee you'll
say oink oink I'm just so happy I got
moed keep American farming going by
signing up at moink box.com Ruben
rightow and listeners of this show get
free ground beef for a year that's one
of the best ground beef you'll ever
taste but for a limited time spelled m o
inkbox.com rubben That's moink box.com
rubben and now back to me you know I
just realized guys I'm suddenly feeling
a little something in my throat that if
I do have coid you guys have nothing to
worry about because no one in this
studio is vaxed so there's just no
problem and I'll be fine don't worry
about that anyway let let's get to
what's going on in the world I mentioned
that that some light is shining through
some of the nonsense because I get it if
you were paying attention to social
media or even mainstream media over the
weekend there are horrible videos and
images not only still coming out of
Israel and just like truly unbearable
unbearable stuff which some of it as
I've said to you guys we're going to
show you a certain amount of it as it
comes out and then there's just a
certain amount I I don't want to
bludgeon you with it you know but it is
important to witness uh the really the
most horrific atrocity of our sort of
modern times let's say last couple
decades uh as it unfolds and that's
exactly what this thing is right uh and
the fact that that Hamas went out of
their way to videotape so much of it we
talked about it last week but the Nazis
they were slaughtering people and doing
Untold things and experiments on
children and all of that and they
weren't they weren't videotaping it for
the world to see they were videotaping
it for their own internal thing and then
it got leaked Hamas is doing this with
the intention to scare people and
promote themselves and and everything
else uh if you want to see some more
we're not going to do any of the the
horrors today actually if you want to
see some more of it because a bunch more
did leak you go to my Twitter and I've
retweeted some things but
anyway the thing that I'm concerned
about at the moment is watching The
Narrative shift so 13,000 Israelis get
slaughtered babies burned people tied
together all of the stuff right you've
seen it um and for about 48 Hours Israel
had the world behind it and then what
always happens in this situation is that
when Israel responds right and Hamas is
the elected government of Gaza okay no
Israelis live there no je Jew lives
there Hitler would love the place uh
when they respond and they use human
Shields and their control center is
under the largest hospital in Gaza these
are facts they they intentionally fire
out of buildings where they know babies
and children are and all that stuff so
it's a double War crime right firing
into civilian areas and then using
civilian Shields but I know they don't
play by rules I think that's one of the
problems we're having in the west right
now we play with some degree of rules
and and you might say we we bludge in
our rules all the time and we cheat and
all that but we have some degree of
humanity and we're play we're fighting
against people that have no degree of
humanity the the the death actually is
what they want the Carnage and the death
on both sides they feel gets them
further to their goals and unfortunately
there's a lot of people in the west who
fall for that nonsense right so they see
images as tragic as they as they are of
dead people in Gaza uh even though
Israel's dropping leaflets and a whole
bunch more to move people out they're
they're still after all of this no army
in the world would ever do this please
leave this area we're going to bomb it
but still after after burn babies burned
alive they're still doing it anyway the
media narrative you can start to see it
shift Israel gets a 48 hour window they
had to make sense of things it takes a
while to figure out a military operation
everything else and then the media
starts shifting and now it's no longer
about that it's suddenly about what's
going to happen to the people of Gaza
and that Israel should have a
proportionate response no other uh
Society in the history of the world no
other civilization has ever been asked
to have a proportionate response it's a
completely ridiculous thing you might
remember the C the Powell Doctrine Colin
Powell when he was Secretary of State
what 25 years ago uh you there's no such
thing as a proportionate response you
have an overwhelming response so that
they don't do it again you don't want to
end up in a war of attrition forever
well anyway this this nonsensical idea
of a proportionate response ask the
Allies if their respons was
proportionate when they were bombing
cities in World War II or when we
dropped nukes on Japan which now we're
an ally with because you end a war
anyway uh Douglas Murray who is just
like the best of the best I'm so proud
to call him a friend and someone I've
been in this battle with uh for many
many years he's been all over the media
here he is on British TV as this uh
ridiculous uh woman this ridiculous
quote unquote journalist uh is concerned
about what's happening in Gaza and
Israel's disproportion
response the siege of Gaza cutting off
all supplies of fuel the electri L
electricity plant that's gone there's no
electricity there's no running water
there is no food going in there are no
other fuel supplies going in borders
closed at Egypt as well bizarrely little
criticism of Egypt for that
interestingly um is that and while
raining down missiles on buildings which
they know are going to kill civilians we
know hundreds and hundreds of civilians
already died many of them children is
that a reasonable proportionate and
moral response by
Israel there is some deep perversion in
Britain whenever Israel is involved in a
conflict and it is the word you just
used proportion proportionate
proportionality only Britain is really
obsessed with this I've heard it for the
last few days incessantly
proportionality and conflict rarely
exists but if we were to decide that we
should have this fetish about
proportionality then that would mean
that in retaliation for what Hamas did
in Israel on Saturday Israel should try
to locate a music festival in Gaza for
instance and good luck with that should
try to find a music festival in Gaza and
rape precisely the number of women that
Hamas raped on Saturday kill precisely
the number of young people that Hamas
killed on Saturday they should find a
town of exactly the same size as a town
like stat where I've been many times
myself and make sure they go to door too
and kill precisely the correct number of
babies that Hamas killed in stat on
Saturday and shoot in the head precisely
the same number of old age pensioners as
were shot in stot on Saturday just to
choose one town I mean does anyone say
it clearer does anyone say it more
succinctly does anyone say it with a
better British accent like it's just
absolutely absurd absolutely abolutely
absurd proportional response and imagine
saying proportional response to a group
of people who are still missing their
children did we even play I can't even
remember which things we've played at
this point did we play the video a
couple days ago of the Hamas guys that
have the babies they literally are
holding the babies yeah um I'm not even
sure if we played that like but you you
people just just proportionately do it
oh and you're only two generations off
the Holocaust we already saw that but
just calm down just calm down it's it's
just it's just epic everyone
knows it is and again they're using
Hamas is going out of its way to use
decency and and the the kindness of
Western Civilization for all of her
flaws they are using it to destroy us
from the inside and people like this
quote unquote journalist that Douglas is
talking to are going ahead and acting as
their useful idiots uh here's one more
Douglas fully explains how Israel is
doing everything they can to reduce
civilian casualties not only because
it's the right thing to do because they
know that the the world will use that
against them proportionate to the threat
as perceived by by America by other
countries we didn't say that the death
toll in Afghanistan had to be precisely
the death toll for instance in the Twin
Towers in New York we didn't take that
view by the way the always has to be
said the difference between the Western
Way of War and the Hamas terrorist way
of war is that their objective is to
kill civilians the objective of Hamas is
to kill innocent people the objective in
conflict of the United States the United
Kingdom Israel and other civilized
democracies is to kill as few innocent
people as possible it cannot be said
enough that Israel tries to use the IDF
to protect its citizenry Hamas uses the
citizenry to try to protect Hamas uh
Israel precisely uses Precision guided
missiles in order to try to limit
civilian casualties but I have no doubt
that after the atrocities of the last
week the appetite of the Israeli public
and Military and politicians to continue
this Precision game will of course
change it's a good point too what he's
saying there at the end it's it's
important to have the mo the moral High
Ground for as long as you can and there
are
things there are Untold evils in this
world I think we've seen a lot of them
in the last week and at some point you
could push the Israelis to say all right
no more leaflets no more caring about
civilians or anything else and by the
way not only I think there would be an
argument that would that it would be
within their right because it would be
within the scope of what humans are able
to do to
survive um but no other country would
have taken these precautions in the
beginning so I wanted to start with
those two clips with Douglas because
we're seeing so much uh amoral unclarity
let's say a bunch of people who don't
see a difference between uh the
barbarity and a civilized uh societ
trying to do the right thing and defend
her people um but there are a couple
other people by the way that are morally
clear and telling the truth about what's
going on one of them another one that
I'm proud to know and support uh is our
governor right here Ronda santis who
talks about what it's like to deal with
a terrorist organization like Hamas
you're running to be the next
commander-in-chief so I want to focus on
some of the crises we're seeing right
now you were once uh a Navy Jag which
means you advised on uh the law of armed
conflict with Israel about to launch
this invasion of Gaza I wonder what you
would advise them in terms of
distinguishing between legitimate
targets and
civilians well one Israel has a right to
defend itself to the hilt and that means
the complete elimination of Hamas the
eradication of their terrorist
infrastructure Israel has put out
warnings to civilians about where Israel
is going to conduct operations and has
told civilians there to leave the area
Hamas is telling those civilians to stay
in the area so they're using the
civilians as human Shields so of course
when you're in war you want to avoid
that but if there are civilian
casualties that's the fault of Hamas
that's not going to be the fault of
Israel but would you advise for example
the Israeli military to avoid attacking
infrastructure to provide water and
electricity as they have
done well Margaret the Hamas is holding
people hostage still you you have
Israelis being held hostage as well as
Americans being held hostage I don't
think they're under but I don't think
they're under an obligation to be
providing water and these utilities
while those hostages are being held
hamash should return those hostages uh
before any discussions are had and it's
a disgrace what they're doing and Israel
has every right to use all the pressure
that they can to get those people back I
always say it's nice when you hear
someone tell the truth it's not that
difficult to tell the truth it's not
that difficult to know what is right and
what is wrong and and the rest of it
Margaret over there basically acting
like the Hamas spokesperson like imagine
Billy think about it for a second
imagine someone murdered your wife and
burned your child would you be giving
them water as they have your other
daughter still now and you don't know
her fate really think of what they are
asking the Israelis to do it is
psychotic and again we know that no
other Nation would be asked to do this
no no Other Nation would have to debate
their defense No Other Nation would have
to debate whatever they were going to do
on the offense debate the morality of it
or anything else but these pathetic hack
journalists at these places like it's so
profoundly ridiculous but just to
illustrate further how the IDF is going
out of their way they are doing
everything humanly possible to not kill
civilians and again Hamas wants
civilians killed they literally there is
there's only a limited amount of roads
really like two roads that'll get you
from Gaza to the Egypt border now of
course Egypt we'll get to this in a
second Egypt doesn't want anyone
Crossing that border right they could
just let all everyone into siai not like
Israel is going to chase them into si uh
but Israel is literally dropping
leaflets look at this this is just a
4-second
video those are yeah it was two seconds
whatever it was those are those are
leaflets that say here's the path for
you to leave right we have to bomb this
area because Hamas is in these Hospital
hospitals Hamas is in these buildings we
know it leave we don't want you to die
Hamas is going out of the way not only
to bomb the roads that people can get
out in uh but they are stealing people's
cars they're doing a whole bunch more so
this is a this is audio of a phone call
you know Israel has people has Gins
because obviously there are good Gins
they have Gins on the ground uh who
right now are trying to explain to the
Israelis where where they can bomb and
what's going on listen to the audio of
this call it's a gazin explaining what
Hamas is doing to stop people from
leaving the areas that are going to be
bombed
[Music]
okay so I think you got it and there's
video evidence evolved that we should
have maybe tomorrow we'll play you they
literally put a bomb in the road so you
see all these cars driving trying to
drive south because they're trying to
clear out Northern Gaza first right you
see all these cars these are families
and everything else and the bomb just
blows up it's not an Israeli rocket it's
a bomb that Hamas put in the road so
they want people to die that's what
Hamas wants they want everyone to die
they want the Israelis to die obviously
and they want their own people to die
because they are fighting a religious
War we have a a a largely secular World
a western world that has some degree of
rules right and wants a sort of I want
to use this word but like believes in
some sort of Multicultural we can have
different religions living together and
all of those things they want some of
that and then we have people fighting
religious War this is a problem but you
know I keep talking about this EGP
Egyptian border here's a tweet from n
wokeness with a couple pictures that'll
really illustrate what's going on Gaza
also shares a border with Egypt to keep
gazin out Egypt built massive parallel
walls wow walls and a super strength
steel underground wall one wall is made
of concrete goes 20 ft high and
underground the other is Stone in
addition to the above underground walls
the area is patrolled by the military
there is only one checkpoint to get in
to the country and it's heavily guarded
believe it or not I've been there um
I've been there I think it's the Rafa
border if I'm not mistaken is the uh can
we confirm that the the Border it is
right uh it's the
Rafa Gateway basically that lets you go
from Israel to sin then to get into
Egypt proper and in 1997 a long time ago
it feels like lifetimes ago for me and
and a long long way from where we are
now because obviously it would be insane
to do now uh I took a bus ride I went
from that border I took like a I think
it was like a 20-hour bus ride with a
zillion stops
uh to get to Cairo and I spent a week in
Egypt that's another story altogether
but the point is Egypt has built a
border and they don't want the
Palestinians in they don't want the
Palestinians in Sinai is largely empty
they could take them in but it's strange
that they don't but okay I think we got
some facts on the ground I've tried to
lay out a case of what's actually
happening but now I want to show you
further I've shown you Douglas Murray
and uh Governor Ronda Sanz making just
clean simple sense about this right I
just want to reiterate one thing that
the Santa said it's like why isn't the
entire world calling right now
everyone's saying Israel has to stop
Israel has to stop there's going to be a
genocide I have heard almost nobody say
how about Hamas release the prisoners
release the captives release the
hostages how about you do that and then
we'll have a pause for 24 hours and
figure something out I don't even think
Biden has done that they have Americans
I mean it's genuinely psychotic but
what's what's interesting and again I
think the Silver Lining it's hard to
talk about a silver lining related to
all this but the Silver Lining is people
who have been on the fence about which
way Western Civilization should go
people who have who have lied about the
good people here in America and tried to
make it seem that Mago was our biggest
problem and everything else there
starting to see something wrong so I'm
going to show you a couple clips from
The View right now and believe it or not
ladies and gentlemen only one of these
clips involved someone saying something
completely insane okay so first off is
Alysa far I've been unbelievably
critical of her I think she's a pet
Republican who's really just in it to
sort of destroy Republicans so you you
know just get marginal Republicans out
there uh but she is
explaining what Hamas is doing as it
relates to infrastructure because
they're talking about water and
electricity and all that for Palestine
to be free for the Palestinian territory
to be free they need to join in ridding
themselves of Hamas plain and simple if
you want to see a 21st century thriving
prosperous Palestinian territory that's
what will happen we they Palestine
receives billions of dollars in foreign
aid from all over the world but Hamas
uses that for its terrorist efforts the
reason they don't have basic
infrastructure the reason that right now
we could see their infrastructure turned
off is because Hamas is living large in
qar all their leaders are in Qatar right
now telling the Palestinian people you
need to sit here and you need to be
willing to die for the cause when we're
not war is hell I I've seen it up close
um there's going to be bad things that
happen but Israel has a right to defend
itself so every now and again people who
get most of the stuff wrong something
happens maybe it's burn babies like it
shouldn't get to that point that it
takes that for get to get these people
to wake up but I'll take it I'll take it
and don't worry for all of you that have
been on the right side of this and you
have friends on the wrong side that are
maybe waking up right now I got to tell
you you're never getting the apology
you're never getting the mayaula the
best you can do is just say okay I'm
glad you're on your way and then you
know keep trying to get them down that
path towards what is true and what is
good and what is right that's really the
best that you can do there but what
Alysa far just said there was right and
to even illustrate that further there's
another video going around we have to be
judic judicious in what we show you here
because I only got a limited amount of
time and you got a Life to Live uh
there's a video going around of Hamas
showing that as other countries gave
them money so they got billions of
dollars in Aid right no Israelis living
there the entire world would have loved
to have said hey look the the Jews all
got out and then they turned this into a
Utopia it would have been a beautiful
thing and they could have done it but
instead they literally and there is a
video showing this that they promoted
they showed their Hamas soldiers
literally taking water infrastructure
pipes that were for water chopping them
up and turning them into missiles that's
what they did and now this one I never
thought I never thought I was going to
say this on this show never God you work
in the mysterious ways you truly do
here's Anna Navaro actually making sense
as a child I lived through a Civil War
in nicara nowhere near the violence and
the level of arms that we're seeing uh
right now but I know what it's like to
be uh a child caught in the crossfire
and the violence and the death created
by adults the way I feel about this is
it's heartbreaking and if you are human
you've got to be just as sad to see
innocent children whether they are
Palestinian or whether they are Israeli
the problem is that Hamas doesn't care
about Israeli children or Palestinian
children what they care about is only
one thing wiping Israel off the face of
the earth that is their sole purpose of
existence and I I was reminded of a of a
quote that I'm going to paraphrase from
Golden Mayer a premiere of in a prime
minister in Israel in the past and she
said if Hamas if Palestinians put down
their weapons today there would be no
more violence if the Jews put down their
weapons today there would be no more
Israel and that is the problem that is
the problem that for Israel this is
about existence man crazy times make
strange bedfellows right so these are
these are lefties who I don't know that
anyone in this space has been more
critical of these women related to
everything and I think that their their
confusion around leftism and what has
been happening in America and the
culture words has led to a lot of this
it really has but finally finally and
and this is I don't know it's a mystery
of life I suppose that something so
insane so brazenly shocking so
unbelievably horrible could happen and
then boom the gates are open and now
once the gates are open the truth will
set you free so I I actually think that
that this could really shift the way
just Joy thinks fundamentally and and
sunny uh not Sunny we'll get to sunny in
a second because she's gone completely
the other way but Anna Navaro and maybe
Alysa far etc etc but now I want to show
you sunny htin sunny host who I have
said repeatedly is the worst wait who I
said oh no no you know it's funny
remember two months ago we did the thing
about who's the worst on The View and I
actually said it was Anna Navaro because
Anna was doing it all from the Comforts
of Florida she lives right here in the
Miami area in Florida but obviously I'm
going to flip that now Sunny host I
always thought that Sunny host was the
worst person but I was giving I was
giving Anna like this like thing CU
you're in Florida doing all this but now
Sunny host has gone in so deep on on the
absolute dishonesty and the obfuscation
of the truth and everything else here
she is listen to her uh not only just
lying about Israel but listen to the way
she speaks look at her body language the
way she's looking she doesn't even
believe her and and that's how
so many of these people operate they
repeat the nonsense that they don't
believe and by way Sunny the Hamas guys
they wouldn't be thrilled with someone
like you either but no I just I you know
I look at this from a legal perspective
and I think that we all know that Hamas
has been designated uh a terror
organization just like many other Terror
organizations have had this designation
like the proud boys here in the United
States um but I but I do think that what
we need to remember is that there is an
international human rights body of law
and when you look at that law part of it
is
retaliation against innocent civilians
collectively is also Terror and is also
a war crime and again those are not my
words those are the words of the law and
the president of the European commission
Ursula vandan said just last year when
we were all talking about Ukraine she
said Russia's attacks against civilian
infrastructure especially electricity
are war crimes cutting off men women
children of water electricity and
heating with winter coming these are
acts of pure Terror and we have to call
it as such you are a human Act of Terror
you clown first off the way the coldness
with which she talks it's so obvious
it's not that she's just so deep in in
the abyss on this it's just so
absolutely crazy again we've Illustrated
repeatedly that Israel is not trying
trying to kill civilians they're going
out of their way the double War crime
the warning people Hamas keeping people
but also this idea she there's something
called the law and this is this is I
would actually say this is a this is a
symptom of a disease of the western
liberal mind there are people trying to
kill you trying to kill everyone you
know who want a world that is in no way
connected to a world that you want to
live in or have lived in and you're
going well we've got a piece of paper
here I've got you see wrote this down
and someone in Brussels signed it and
said we've got ways that we're supposed
to behave D you're not allowed to just
behead and burn children I have it on
this oh I got a paper cut you see it's
it's
absolutely bananas she's an
idiot she knows she's an idiot you think
Hamas or any of these people care about
international law so you're making
civilized people play by rules that the
people who are literally beheading them
would never play by it's so absolutely
insane on top of the fact that she tried
and even as she was saying it and this
is how you know this is prepackaged
nonsense and this is put out there by
ABC intentionally when she went out of
her way to say that Hamas is has been
designated a terrorist organization the
Imp the implication she's trying to say
is that it's not really a terrorist they
well they were designated they beheading
people but they were design just like
the proud boys right the proud boys as
far as I know have not beheaded anybody
or burned couples together or held any
hostages or anything else anyway Matt
Walsh from the daily wire he commented
on that I thought this was pretty good
if you put it side the fact that the
proud boys have never launched a
military offensive and slaughtered
hundreds of innocent people and if you
put aside the dozens of other crucial
differences then yes the proud boys are
pretty much the exact uh pretty much
exactly the same as Hamas great point
just profoundly ridiculous but okay so
I've shown you some positive people
coming out of the media and some light
breaking through the darkness and it is
hard to do uh but unfortunately the
darkness is kind of everywhere and it's
going to continue because again the
narrative is going to slightly shift
right now uh the
horrors obviously of these people that
are still held hostage babies there are
babies there being held by terrorists it
was one of the most chilling videos I've
ever seen especially having just spent
the weekend sleeping on the floor with
Luke with coid because you didn't want
to be in the crib and it's like I'm
talking about all this stuff during the
day and then what you would do like what
you would do as a human being when your
baby is crying for two seconds right and
think about what these people are going
through and we're watching The Narrative
shift in real time now the victims
somehow are the Palestinians it's insane
but this is what the mainstream media
does with everything so Drew Holden
who's quite good i' I've played a bunch
of or I've read a bunch of his Twitter
threads uh over the years on the show
he's a reporter at the Washington Beacon
uh he wanted to expose with a thread a
bunch of the nonsense coming out of
mainstream media so here here's what he
wrote a barbaric attack that killed over
a thousand Israelis brought out the
worst from the mainstream media I want
to walk you through some of the terrible
examples and now here's a bunch of
tweets that he quoted things on here's
from NBC
the UN various human rights groups and
legal Scholars citing the blockade
consider Gaza to still be under military
occupation by Israel just real quick you
can come back to me on this one we have
we have already Illustrated this I think
Egypt is also blockading it nobody talks
about that when the Israelis left in
2005 there was no blockade they said we
want nothing to do with you people take
our green houses take our temples they
ransacked all of it and then they
started launching Rockets So Israel said
oh we got to blockade this thing so it's
just again this is one of those things
they're just are not going to let Israel
win in anyway here's one from NPR LED
off this conversation with a stirring
defense of the terrorist's decision to
kill people this is obviously Drew
explaining it see for yourself the top
military commander Hamas said forces
attacked Israel in part because of
recent Israeli raids happening in the
old city of Jerusalem and around the Alo
mosque I want to show you a picture of
uh the old city of Jerusalem and alas
This Is Us in uh this is back in may now
what you're seeing there that's me with
with Ambassador David fredman who was on
the show last week you guys know I've
I've said it a million times how
peaceful Jerusalem was how there are
religious Ultra religious Muslim women
walking next to ultra religious uh
Jewish men there's the Christian quarter
where the Church of the Holy Seiler is
it is literally the most integrated
place in the entire Middle East there is
no city that has more people of
different faiths living for the most
part peacefully together uh she's
talking about the alox of musk what
you're seeing right behind Ambassador
Freedman sort of to the bottom there CU
we're on a high as you can see we're on
the top of a building here uh is the
Western Wall now the Western Wall is the
holiest site in Judaism which before
1967 Jews could not pray at because it
was controlled by Jordan there was no
State and never has been a state known
as Palestine go back go back to the
picture for just a sec um so it's the
Western Wall and that's where Jews pray
but it's actually not the holiest site
the holiest site is above that where the
Dome of the Rock is and you can see the
Dome of the Rock the big gold Dome there
because they built a mosque on top of
what was the ancient Jewish temple that
the temple that Jesus would pray to so
who do you think was there first whether
you think that matters or not but
they're claiming that somehow it's
Israel that's going after alak aamos one
one more time to the to the picture alas
alak aamos is a little bit to the right
side of the picture uh on the other side
of the it's where those trees are
basically and there's a little bridge if
you look on the right side of the
picture there's a little bridge that
allows some tourists to go up there they
really don't let Jews and they certainly
don't let Israelis go up there I
actually did go up there back in 19 97
and it was very clear that they did not
want us there but literally quite
literally that's also where the holiest
side of Judaism where Israel doesn't
even let Jews pray in the name of Peace
so again everything they say is nonsense
here's one from the Washington Post is
this one's just absolutely incredible
this is absolutely incredible
Israel's Iron Dome defense system
protects Israeli lives it also
perpetuates the Israeli Gaza conflict
now this happens to be from 21 May of 21
but it illustrates the absurdity here
Israel has put their money into building
a defense system who who in their right
mind would have thought 20 years ago you
would have to build something right out
of literally out of Star Wars where
people would endlessly fire
indiscriminate rockets at you from every
which direction and you'd be blowing
them out of the sky but Israel said ah
this this is this is how these people
behave uh we might have to do that uh
and they're claiming that that is what's
extending the conflict think about it if
Israel didn't have the Iron Dome if
right now is there was no Iron Dome Gaza
and hezb in the north they're firing
Rockets all just imagine it's your home
you're in America right got bombs flying
from Mexico flying from Canada if those
bombs were all falling you would be far
more warranted to do whatever the hell
you wanted to do the fact that the Iron
Dome exists is one of the things that
actually restrains Israel and then you
have these complete abject morons
islamist apologists and members of the
Hamas caucus like AOC who says oh poor
poor Gaza they don't have an Iron
Dome because they were building a terror
organization anyway here is uh MSNBC
host and MSNBC has been absolutely
horrible on this their numbers are
tanking because of it because you can't
you know people can people can eat a lot
of they really can you feed people
they'll eat but eventually The
Lies start catching up to you over time
uh Med Hassan who is absolutely one of
the worst on MSNBC uh here he is
rationalizing Hamas when you don't give
people hope they turn to the arms of
groups like Hamas now thank you my
friend thank you my friend hope they
didn't give people hope again they took
every Israeli out there are luxury
hotels in Gaza it is in no way
comparable to awit or an open air prison
or anything else it's on the same
Coastal Beach of the Mediterranean that
Tel Aviv is which is one of the most
beautiful beaches in the entire world
they could have turned it into the the
they could have turned it into like the
gem of the Middle East because so many
people would have been so happy that
that something good had happened there
and they decided to turn it into a a
terror Haven anyway here's Med Hassan a
couple years ago calling non-believers
cattle and unintelligent because they
don't believe in Islam the go the
disbelievers the atheists Who Remain
deaf and stubborn to the teachings of
Islam the rational message of the Quran
they are described in the Quran as
quotes a people of no intelligence Allah
describes us not of no morality not of
no belief a people of no intelligence
because they are incapable of the
intellectual effort it requires to shake
off those blind prejudices to shake off
those easy assumptions about this world
about the existence of God so Medi
Hassan it's a little unclear to me
whether he's been suspended right now or
temporarily taken off the I mean he was
running cover for days for Hamas and
explaining why they were basically
basically rationalizing he's one he's
one of these just like deeply
duplicitous people and msnbc's numbers
are tanking right now again because
think about it think about who watches
MSNBC you have mostly like sort of the
woke left the like elitist liberal and
it's not that many people right because
our show gets more people they have
million they have hundreds of millions
of dollars before them and they wish
they could get it by the end of the day
what we get on this show right across
platforms um but people but they have
brainwashed people but even the
brainwashed people have had it like
enough brainwashed people saw um like
again I don't want to get into all the
atrocities every time but saw the stuff
and then they realized this should be
not excused so their numbers are tanking
medy at least has somewhat been
temporarily taken off the air uh here's
some info from the New York Post it's
got a little snark I I actually love the
New York Post uh MSNBC is dishonest
journalism that draws a false
equivalence between the terrorist
brutalities of Hamas and the legitimate
self-defense of Israel the network lost
33% of its prime time viewers since
Hamas struck Israel even as Fox which
accurately reports on the situation has
seen a massive 42% jump in total
viewership it's not hard to see why
Americans know what terrorism looks like
the rape and murder of civilians
including toddlers the desperate
pretenses of MSNBC hosts like Hamas fan
Andrea Mitchell I like that line can't
convince any sane person otherwise it
was Mitchell remember who had the insane
Gall to suggest Hamas and Israel really
aren't so different to an Israeli mother
whose children the terror squads are
holding hostage one is the Region's
strongest democracy and our closest
local Ally the other is a Cadre of
genocidal islamists working to further
Iran's Ambitions the networks pulled
other similar moves like lumping
together the death tolls from Gaza and
Israel on on an on-screen graphic except
that those Gaza tools are driven by a
Hamas policy of sitting mer uh military
personnel and material in mosques and
hospitals and encouraging civilians to
stay in places where Israel has notified
it will be bombarding and bringing on
the trio of Ahmad madin Medi Hassan and
Ali veli to say Hamas the Hamas assault
was the result of failed policies by
Israel and the US the ratings punishment
slamming MSNBC shows that this flood of
propaganda doesn't work the real
question is when the leg Legacy media
media will admit it to be clear this is
not cancel culture every company has a
can decide whether they want to work
with people who in a war are lying for
the bad guys while their ratings are
tanking I suspect actually had they been
lying for Hamas and running cover for
heras as they've done for a long time
and Andrea Mitchell who's a Jew pathetic
uh I suspect had they been doing all
that and their ratings going up these
people would be there it's it's a
business decision uh anyway they are
they are the MSNBC is the med a wing of
Hamas as as the as
AOC and ilhan Omar and the rest of them
they're the Hamas caucus that's what
these people are doing but the point is
again that silver lining thing people
are kind of waking up to some of the
by the way you know last week I
tried a couple times to connect a lot of
what's going on here to all of the lies
that we've been fed like related to
everything BLM and boys or girls and
blah blah blah do you remember since
we're talking about Andrea Mitchell that
Andrea Mitchell was the one who when
they kept lying about uh Ronda santis
what he was doing with that
African-American studies AP course
saying they were kept saying that he was
saying that slavery was good for black
people and all that she was the one that
interviewed Camala Harris and basically
said that and what what does Ronda
santis not want people to know about
black history so she has lied about
everything so these people who have lied
about everything then Their audience
becomes a bunch of morons and confused
about everything and then they wonder
why you are an embarrassment an epic
embarrassment Andrea Mitchell but go to
ham go to Gaza and see how they treat
Jewish Elite journalists I'm guessing
not that well yeah help no nobody thinks
that well uh anyway I want to show you a
little bit of the also Stark difference
that's happening across the world right
now because we're seeing these protests
pop up all over the place and there is a
a really fundamental difference between
the behavior of what's happening for
these pramas and yes they are pramas uh
River to the Sea protests there's nobody
at these protests that's like guys
actually could we just return to the 19
67 lines and what Hamas has done is bad
they they would be beaten to death okay
these are these are pro genocide
protests vers the Israeli protest so
first a headline from the midwesterner
we are ready to die scenes from the pro
Hamas March in Dearborn Michigan now we
showed you some of the uh video out of
Dearborn Michigan that's Rashida tb's
District where they had this massive I
don't know several thousand people
basically not a modern Nazi rally uh we
got we got some problems there uh here's
San Diego yeah it's happening in San
Diego there was one woman one lone woman
with an Israeli flag and here's how
these tolerant and decent leftists
treated
[Applause]
[Music]
her kids like go go to Gaza you
purple-haired see what happens um
anyway here here here's a compilation of
pro Gaza protests at Wisconsin
University of Wisconsin UCLA and Harvard
all places that I've spoken all places
I've been heavily protested except
University of Wisconsin I don't know
what that was about maybe I don't know
maybe the leftist wack jobs took the day
off to the murders glory to glory to the
murders glory to the do you know what he
say when we say we will Liberate the
Land There you go do this with
[Applause]
[Music]
okay first off I just want to be clear
about something these are these are
radical LEF lunatics these kids the
system has failed them which puts them
out there the fact that so many of them
are wearing masks they're either still
confused about Co or they're they're
doing it because they don't want people
to know what they're actually doing
because they might want to get hired at
a job one day um but I do want to rest
assured that this is not how most people
think um wide widely across the West uh
people know what right and wrong is but
it is important to expose this nonsense
but again it's important to illustrate
because this is happening all over
Europe and it's much more intense
actually in Europe you know the land
will be liberated do you think that they
are going to stop with Israel if these
people think that Israel that the Jews
have nothing to do with Israel um do you
think that they think that America is a
just
experiment you see what decolonization
really is all about this is this is a
intensely focused and coordinated
movement to upend all of Western society
and these these it's I hate to tell you
I hate to tell you for the for the
people that are waking up right now and
I know there's a whole bunch I just
showed you some clips of the women of
the view you guys also need a mirror in
the midst of all this I don't want a dog
pile on you as you're actually waking up
because it's a beautiful thing and I
went through a wake up many years ago is
what it is but why is it that these
University Harvard Harvard is supposed
to be our most elite place of education
for young people in the entire country
now yes we've known for years that it
discriminates actually it used to have
quotas against Jews and then it had
quotas against Asian people so it
shouldn't really surprise us this is
exactly what it is and now I want to
show you the absolute absurdity of
what's going on if you if you think the
protest and that they're going to
liberate the land they don't even know
what the hell they're talking about they
have no idea of basic history or
anything else it's just it's youthful
just nonsense all that fine uh here's
the president of Harvard Claudine gay
and here she is explaining why these
protests should be allowed now now try
to imagine if these protests were magga
protests try to imagine if these
protests were I don't know against
vaccines or against mandates what she
would be saying try to imagine imag if
these protests were I don't know a bunch
of girls who didn't want dudes with
dicks swimming against
them and now listen to the utter
hypocrisy of This Woman This is a moment
of intense pain and grief for a great
many people in our community and around
the world I feel that pain and grief
myself as members of a university
community we have a
choice we can fan the Flames of division
and Hate hatred that are roing the
world or we can try to be a force for
something different and
better people have asked me where we
stand so let me be
clear our University rejects terrorism
that includes the barbaric atrocities
perpetrated by
Hamas our University rejects hate hate
of Jews hate of Muslims hate of any
group of people based on their faith
their national origin or any aspect of
their
identity our University rejects the
harassment or intimidation of
individuals based on their
beliefs and our University Embraces a
commitment to free
expression that commitment extends even
to views that many of us find
objectionable even
outrageous we do not punish or sanction
people for expressing ing such
views we should have put a laugh track
in that for every dishonest thing that
she said she doesn't give a about
Free Speech or anything else they gladly
would have kicked people out of the
school and did for not abiding by their
vaccine policies or mandates again I I
Illustrated several examples of things
that she would never be supporting right
a Maga group shows up at campus you
think she'd be giving that talk a girls
who want to swim with girls group shows
up and that's not a lesbian joke that's
just girls used to swim with girls
that's how they'd race everything they
say is a lie but James Lindsay you guys
know James Lindsay I've had him on the
show many times James is one of the
clearest thinkers literally in the world
I think when it comes to let's get James
on next week by the way and by also we
are going to continue doing this thing
where we have guests join us in the
middle of the show I think we're doing
it every day this week except for today
uh but James Lindsay um has been
exposing how how evil the woke thing is
and how it how it basically uses all of
our strengths and turns them into
weaknesses so he saw that video uh by
the Harvard president he wrote this
Communists only appeal to your values
when they're losing and or manipulating
you with them and that is exactly what
she's doing there she does not care
about Free Speech she doesn't care if
kids are intimidated imagine if you were
just the average Jewish kid you don't
have to be Israeli you're a Jewish kid
or you're just like a pro-america kid
and these rallies are going by your dorm
room and everyone's screaming and
everything else and from the river to
the SE and you're just like I don't
really want to be invol involved in that
guess what you're going on a list with
these people too you really are but
again now I want to show you that
somehow light is coming through it's
really bizarre uh TMZ have we ever
played a clip from TMZ on this show
ever yeah maybe something with Kanye
years ago TMZ which TMZ is just like
this big gossip rag you you've all seen
it in things over the years it's become
like a a really huge cultural
institution well here is TMZ fully uh
doing something right and true and wow
and black lives matter in
Chicago embraced the killing of Jews
they are Hitler hold on they are
hitleresque they are a hitleresque
organization to do something like that
period they these are Nazis essentially
trying to exterminate Jews and they are
embraced by black lives matter in
Chicago it is
disgusting what's his name over TMZ
what's that guy's name again anyone
remember
like credit where credit is due like I
don't really care about all the gossip
and all the rest of it uh oh Harvey um
Harvey Lan yeah like good good good good
and true but now I want to connect you
know there are these protests and of
course they're happening all over the
world uh and I want to connected to
something else because Friday as you may
remember was uh what it was national day
of jihad or something I they didn't
really pull off much I think one there
was one Israeli uh consulate worker in
China I think that was stabbed and one
French teacher that was killed
horrible things right horrible things
but you know people thought it was going
to be much worse so thank God for that
um but the point is that a lot of this
stuff the plan is to export it you know
one of the things that's coming or that
they're now telling us is that Hamas was
basically working on this plan for two
years now we have had two years of an
open border do you think there is a plan
in place
already like does that make me crazy or
conspiracy theorist I mean think about
it so here is FBI director Chris Ray
saying oh yeah something might happen
here in this heightened environment
there's no question we're seeing an
increase in reported threats and we've
got to be on the lookout especially for
lone actors who may take inspiration
from recent events to commit violence of
their own so I'd encourage you to stay
vigilant because as the first line of
defense protecting our communities
you're often the first to see the signs
that someone may be mobilizing to
violence I'd also ask you to continue
sharing any intelligence or observations
you may have and on our end we're
committed to doing the same so that
together we can Safeguard our
communities think how really crazy this
is we have watched two years basically
since day one of the Biden
administration of opening our borders
right I've shown you a million Clips
you've all seen them we don't know who's
coming through we don't know what
they're doing what their allegiance are
on top of the fact that it's just simply
not morally or legally right to just
have an open border but especially in a
time of like sheer Insanity right like
this isn't this isn't like taking some
Polish immigrants in 1950 right like
this is a completely different thing
okay but we could all have our own
personal feelings on how many people we
should take if any at all I think at the
very least you have to have a border
first but basically he's saying uh yeah
uh they're probably here they're
probably here and they're probably going
to do some bad stuff so could you keep
an eye out you know sure we we let them
in like this Administration is is an
utter embarrassment this Administration
is is tacitly offering to burn up the
United States they lit the fire of
letting everyone in here and now they're
going well it's kind of on you guys
could you just call somebody if you see
anything but that could we do that um so
the issue here is that we don't want to
step on the First Amendment we don't
want to step on someone's right to free
speech but again the first amendment has
limitations right you cannot directly
threaten to murder people which in
essence a lot of these protests are
doing uh you canot not directly threaten
violence you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater with the intent to do
harm so but you we want to protect our
laws and our god-given rights to the
best of our ability while a group of
people who would gladly upend them and
never respect them are coming to destroy
everything right but we we have to
figure out what that balance is it is
freaking tough but we don't want to stop
people who are legally here from
speaking within the legal limits of the
law but we know we have we know we have
an awful amount of illegal people here
know that they are participating in
these rallies and the question is what
do you do with them well Ronda Sanz has
an idea and as I'm looking at those
protests and those demonstrations in
these cities where these people are
cheering Hamas who has beheaded infants
uh raped women assassinated elderly
people the barbarism is the most
disgusting thing I've seen you look at
Isis you look at Al-Qaeda I don't think
they went to this depth for what Hamas
is doing so we have people that are
cheering that and my view is is nobody
has a right to come to this country and
if you don't like this country then you
should get out of this country you
should not be allowed to come here in
the in the first place uh if you don't
share the values of the United States of
America and I think we've allowed people
to come in illegally who reject our
values but I think we've also allowed
people to come legally who reject our
values and if we don't have any any type
of common currency that ties us together
as a people uh this country is just not
going to succeed so yes I'd be I'd be
strong on on legal immigration to make
sure that we're vetting people that are
coming in and the only reason to have
people come in is because it benefits
the United States of America and our
people it's not because you have an
entitlement as a foreign citizen to come
in yeah America first remember America
First have a border know who's here
decide judiciously whether we should
have more people and do they fit into
the Melting Pot that is America the
Melting Pot that those people are going
to upend so try to imagine as you're
watching and again you could say oh
they're just waving the Palestinian flag
and they're not supporting Hamas but do
you think there is literally one person
at those protests who's like guys guys
Hamas is bad we should have a peaceful
resistance and beheading babies is bad
they would be treated like the average
Israeli or anything else at those
protests right there is nobody and we
know this because this is what the left
has done with everything they always go
to their most extreme so we are watching
it happen right now now I will tell you
as as chilling as it is when you see
these protests in Chicago and you see
these protests in New York and we're
seeing them in Canada and we saw the gas
the Jews one in uh in Sydney Australia
and everything else as chilling as all
that is Western Europe has a much bigger
problem because they have let in
hundreds of thousands of these people
and they have to figure out what they're
going to do and and it again there's
that that fine line between free speech
and actually upholding laws and making
sure that all your citizens feel safe
and everything else uh here is Douglas
Murray once again on what you have to do
with these people who are who are openly
calling for genocide they are fine with
terrorist attacks and they are brazenly
expressing that on the Streets of London
I came back to London the other night
and I hear the residue of the people
outside the Israeli Embassy these people
were not protesting against Israeli
countermeasures they hadn't even had any
counter
measures they were protesting because
Jews by the hundreds had been
slaughtered in Israel and they wanted to
wound us
more well they might
try but we should not accept that with
equinity I've written in The Spectator
tomorrow a demand on the Prime Minister
and the Home Secretary that supporters
of Hamas in the UK must be treated in
exactly the same way as supporters of
Isis were
this some people thought that the claim
that Hamas was Isis was a rhetorical
claim we know since Saturday if we
didn't know before it is not rhetoric it
is real if you stand in Britain with a
Hamas flag you should not be allowed to
be free in
Britain you should be arrested have your
citizenship withdrawn your passport
withdrawn you should be deported you
should be sent to the Gaza and try your
luck
there but you should not be given the
right to insult and to taunt Jews after
the death of Jews it's intolerable and
we should not tolerate it but I'll go a
step further and then we're going to
show you some video of what's going on
in London it's not it's not that you
just Jews this isn't just Jews the
average Brit who once had a country that
was British and believed in Law and
Order and was a a flourishing thriving
nation has been largely demolished so
now I want to show you uh we're going to
show you some of the protest from London
I think we're going to keep my mic on
for this so this is London in the last
two
days free Palestine free Palestine now
do you think they mean oh go back to the
1967 border and then blah blah blah but
the issue is not even that if they wiped
out all of the Jews what do you think
these people in Britain do you think
they would be feeling negated or they'd
be feeling energized to now bring it to
Britain which they believe to be even a
worse colonizer project and now here's
Britain 60 years
[Music]
ago
what do you think those people from
London 60 years ago would think of the
London of today some of those people
they might still be alive right if you
were 30 60 years ago you're 90 now do
you think things have gone the right way
or the wrong way do you think that the
people that are out there chanting for
genocide and everything else do you
think they want a Britain that your
children are going to live safely in
that is that is going to respect any
Western value or anything else or are
they on a holy religious War I mean just
what do you think and again if they take
out Israel you think they're going to be
like okay pack it up guys like no of
course not it will it will just be the
beginning and also when you see those
thousands and thousands of people in
London um who who seems more indigenous
to the land would you say would you say
that Jews are more indigenous to the
ancient land of
Israel the land of Abraham and Isaac and
Jesus or those guys in London who's more
indigenous you got it you got it but how
about one more of those because
Stockholm Sweden also had crazy protest
so we're going to show you some of the
Stockholm Sweden protests of the weekend
and Stockholm Sweden you know by the way
the leftists were always saying can't
America be more like the Nordic
countries can't we be more like Norway
and Sweden and Denmark then of course
they let in a whole bunch of people uh
that they shouldn't have let in and now
the countries are having major major
problems but here's Stockholm Sweden uh
yesterday versus Stockholm SW versus
Sweden 68 years
[Applause]
[Music]
ago
you got it you got it I don't think I
have to add anything else so the West
left did decide what the West will do
and America will have to decide what
America wants to do Europe has a much
ver a much worse version of this America
has done a way better job integrating
people into society and creating a
Melting Pot not creating oh you're this
color you should live there and
everything else right that's what's
happened in Sweden that's what happened
in France and everywhere else and not
just allowing hundreds of thousands of
people to pour through America didn't do
that until this last year or so now we
have a big problem on our hands they
have a much worse problem we could have
shown you those same videos from Paris
right we could have shown you them in uh
Belgium we could have showed you them in
Netherlands they all exist what these
places are going through now vers what
they uh were like 50 60 70 years ago so
all of these places will have to decide
and we will have to ultimately deal with
the challenge of how do we
remain decent Western Civilization that
defends free speech and everything else
as we as as the Enemy Within loves the
fact that we don't know what to do with
that loves the fact that they can use
all our goodness against us right I
would also remind you that uh there were
no protests no Hamas protests in
Poland none Poland a lot of Polish jokes
how many Polish people does it keep to
build a wall you know you got it okay
fine but Poland said no none of you
people and they're doing just fine
wouldn't that be the ultimate irony
Poland would be like you people made a
lot of jokes about us but we have a
civilization and you don't haha who won
uh all right guys that is our show for
today thanks for tuning in as always if
you haven't subscribed over on Rumble
please go ahead and do that because
again the YouTube thing it's like who
knows how long it'll work and if you
want to join us for the postgame show if
you want to get messages directly to me
if you want to ask us things and and get
involved in our Q&A and a whole bunch
more Ruben report. locals.com my full
interview with Megan Kelly is up it's up
everywhere now yeah it's up everywhere
right now she's just she's just so great
you know three people I think have
really shined for the last week and I'm
so proud to to call them all friends I
would say it's Megan Kelly it's Dan
Bonino and and Douglas Murray
specifically Jordan Maybe for Jordan
Peterson like just like just standing up
for what is right oh you know what I'm
going to be on Sean Spicer show in about
15 minutes so we're going to do a quick
post game I thank you guys for watching
we're back at it tomorrow all right
[Music]
ciao